Sammis beer with epi and Z's we are here
on the Golan Heights and we are looking
into Syria site of just the worst civil
war imaginable Syrians who are wounded
or in need of medical attention have
been getting medical attention from the
Israelis sometimes they're wounded and
sometimes those are sick women or
children I cannot imagine how they feel
you know sometimes they come and they
they're just so scared and you know you
can barely get them talk and sometimes
they say Dada thank you and Hebrew
that's thank you Hebrew is pretty
special
yes and Icahn's here that's a civil what
we're hearing right now right now is
it's change of fire between the regime
and the rippers that's the city of new
cuneta that city is controlled by the
regime okay by Assad's military and the
village right here is controlled by
rebels
that's machine-gun fire with your rifle
fire machine gun heavy machine gun yep
this is going on all the time this is
relatively calm pain relatively calm
relative to war that's why that's
relatively calm as they come yeah I've
never heard an actual war before that's
that's pretty sobering Syrians are
treated near the border and then they're
taken here standing here with dr.
Rosenthal
and with Farris and dr. Rosenthal
obviously you treat the Syrians that
come here they need help and Ferris you
are a social worker you speak Arabic and
you say that's important because when
the Syrians come in they're very afraid
so if someone can speak Arabic to them
it calms them is that right yes you're
treating Syrians here who've been
injured in the Civil War you don't treat
them just medically they're also treated
psychologically is that true yeah not
true because there's some people that
have illnesses and they also come here
because I have a trauma right have a
trauma from the war
mmm-hmm have a trauma for leaving the
country yeah I think you're doing God's
work here at honestly sincerely think
you're doing beautiful work here the
only thing I question about you are
these medical crops that I think is the
only thing that separates you from
godlike status yeah we all have our
mistakes
you saw them at the wall you had to have
them other than the Crocs I think you
should get the Peace Prize I really do
next I visited with some of the Syrian
poisons he faces we had to blur for
their own protection please tell him
that I'm very sorry for his injury in
his pain and coming here and seeing
everyone here who's been injured and
meeting them it's very powerful for me
the world is very aware of the horrors
in Syria and we're hoping that together
maybe we can find a solution so that
this can stop how to be there save our
chefs we shall learn by bath without any
side salon tech Salam Tech Salam
[Applause]
you